and this is a memo that came out
yesterday morning from the national
football league as it relates to the
wearing of face coverings
by coaches and sideline personnel during
games and quick summary week one
there were some failures by coaches and
sideline personnel to properly wear face
covering so the nfl huffed and puffed
and based on week two blew down the
houses financially of five coaches and
their teams to the tune of 1.75 million
in total fines for blatantly failing to
wear the face coverings not just well it
wasn't covering your nose or you pulled
it down too many times it was just
blatant screw you we're just gonna leave
we're just gonna leave it here but we're
not gonna use it week three going into
week three
the hope was everything would be fine
coming out of week three the initial
reaction the report card from the league
was fine nobody got fined but then they
sent out this memo that huffs and puffs
again and says look we've seen
improvement but there's still guys on
the sideline who aren't complying so we
need to see compliance and oh by the way
if we don't suspensions and forfeiture
of draft picks are on the table and
chris it's this weird pendulum for the
nfl
it's hit him hard one week but then back
off the next week because i think they
don't want it to be a big national story
right but then threaten to hit him again
if they don't do a better job and then
maybe they will hit him again and then
back off because they don't want it to
be a national story i mean i've seen
this with the nfl in a variety of things
where they don't want certain topics to
overcome the game yeah we want to talk
about the game don't talk about these
other things going into week three we're
not talking about the masks anymore
right we're talking about the game well
now we're worried about the masks again
and i think this is going to be a
continuous theme
i don't know that the threat of
suspensions or draft picks will make
much of a difference i think just like
with the fines
to get full compliance at all times with
the face coverings they are going to
have to suspend somebody or take away a
draft pick and then after that i think
that's when teams finally get the
message that you can't have these shots
at the sidelines where you can see
that there are some folks who aren't
fully complying with the face covering
requirement it's not blatant but they're
not fully complying i think we don't get
to that point where we see full
compliance until
they do suspend someone or take away
someone's draft pick well yeah i i mean
agreed first of all you're right it's
kind of been a little bit of up and down
and all over the place here which is
rare for the nfl because usually they
like you know
draw a concrete line and like or go nope
you can't cross that and if you do you
knew that line was there and that's it
disagree
well okay i mean i well i feel like that
way for players for mostly i do disagree
okay disagree
one thing i've learned let me i don't
want to spend a whole lot of time on
this but here's the comparison
when it comes to what they're going to
do for players who commit egregious acts
on the field i know there have been
times where they've stopped short of
suspending a player who deserved to be
suspended either because they don't want
it to be a big story or because they
don't want to force an appeal that they
lose because they're not sure they're
going to win because the appeal process
isn't run by the nfl there have been
times where they've exercised discretion
and not suspended someone who should
have been suspended for reasons other
than whether or not the guy should have
been suspended okay so there is that
that pendulum idea that and it's driven
by pr ultimately that has applied as it
relates to players but go ahead well
okay well we're still sitting here
talking about the mass so great pendulum
theory i mean it's not working then
again this week all right so you know oh
they sent the memo that's the thing
what the guys and then next week they're
going to shut up about the masks and the
pendulum is going to be over i know i'm
just glad you've learned how to say
pendulum no but i what i don't
understand is like okay wait this is not
that hard you want the optics right we
know my thought a little bit on this
already i mean this is no safer
environment like in the world right now
than that and i know that's not perfect
because we've seen tennessee and what's
going on there this week i get it um my
thing is the coaches that were fined
last week i didn't see their masks ever
come down last week you know they never
i mean kyle shanahan had that thing
glued on his face last week he wasn't
gonna lose another hundred thousand
dollars every time
yeah every time i saw pete carroll it
was all the way up there like a suction
cup down there so
you know again i thought too because
there was an incident on monday night
remember john harbaugh early in the game
he had a down he was in the ref's face
yelling and things like that and i went
whoa there goes a hundred that's a
hundred thousand dollar conversation
right there he's gonna get fined for
that i was kind of shocked and yeah i
saw a number of guys on sunday where it
comes down for a period of time and you
yell and you talk and then they put it
back up but
if they're worried about the optics the
only way that that's going to stop is
like what you're what you're saying is
you're going to have to just hit them
hard you know 100 000 was very hard you
know you can't do that to the assistant
coaches if you want to do that the head
coach who's making millions and millions
and millions that's okay i can live with
that but i think that you know in this
case money talks and money will
money will make mass go up in in this
case if that's what the nfl is worried
about
here's the other reality too the more
the nfl pushes this issue the more the
nfl ventures into that minefield where
the people out there who are convinced
that masks don't work right who refuse
to wear masks and think anyone who wears
a mask is a sucker and a loser those are
the people who are going to begin
huffing and puffing about turning off
the nfl i'm not going to watch these
games we're going to boycott the nfl
they're trying to force masks onto
everyone can you believe what they did
to my favorite team they took away their
fifth round draft pick because the coach
pulled his mask down because they
couldn't hear him so they had to see his
lips to supplement what they were
hearing so they could understand the
message that's where that could go and i
think that's one of the reasons why you
see this kind of awkward tightrope walk
where that bar is swinging like this
because they can't get a proper balance
on how best to handle it you mentioned
harbaugh here's harbaugh talking about
his failure to have his mask up at all
times specifically when he was chewing
out an official during monday night's
game
we have been for all three games you
know really good on the sideline i don't
think is anybody better than us me or
our staff from the beginning of the game
to the end of the game so to think in a
you know three-hour heated
competitive environment that you know
especially when you're yelling that your
mask isn't gonna fall down or whatever
uh for five or ten seconds i think
that'd be uh i think anybody couldn't be
held to that standard that
uh would be a little hard for anybody to
hold on to so
i feel really good about the job i'm
doing i feel really good about the job
our team is doing and we'll continue to
do our best last week was the first time
that
did it every single play kept it on
throughout the whole game
it's not the most fun thing as everyone
realizes but it's definitely worth it
and something we need to do
oh it's worth it in many ways it's worth
the tune of a hundred thousand dollars
out of your pocket
and look my coffee
at some point the mask the mask he's
wearing yeah see how it's attached
around his ear yeah it can never come
down
it's not coming down right and and chris
john harbaugh should take a page from
his mentor's playbook there he is andy
reid
wear the welder's mask right they can
see your lips when you're yelling your
your headset can go right down
underneath and you can call your plays
if you need to be able to let people see
your mouth moving so they hear what
you're saying wear the welder mask it's
that simple yeah it's compliant right
and it works
and again they all need to see they all
need to be able to protect themselves
from themselves in those moments and the
shanahan loops around the ears it's too
hard to pull it down so i'm not going to
do it but you've got that neck gator
it's too easy for it to fall down you
know oh it fell down because my my hand
supplemented the force of gravity and
yanked it down so uh look and now now
the nfl's making it clear suspensions
draft picks on the table draft pixel
what will get a team's attention 250
thousand dollars in theory should get
their attention as well but the draft
picks you know that each one is a
potential hall of famer yeah don't touch
our draft picks even though they get
squandered
yeah you know it's it's it's so funny
how they view that you know the draft
picks are so much more valuable before
they're used after they're used well who
knows what happens but uh maybe maybe
we'll see this week starting tonight
yeah with and don't just look at the
head coaches folks
look at the the shots of the sidelines
and we'll see what kind of compliance we
have and we'll see whether or not that's
going to lead to further discipline
yeah no i i agree like i said i saw that
a number of times last week and that's
where i probably think the whole like
finding the team draft pick things comes
in because i don't think the nfl wants
to take money away from the assistant
coaches who are making good money but
you know not not
nfl football player money all the time
like that you know and and that's that's
where it's uh a little tricky but i
would think most of the coaches because
of this memo and knowing how serious it
is and that the nfl is continuing to
look at this and really give no wiggle
room that that even a guy like harbaugh
who goes it's not realistic like this
week i bet you see that thing glued up
on his face too because he's gonna go
damn i'm sick of asking answering
questions about it and dealing with it
let me just keep this damn thing up and
not have to deal with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports